Within the first few days of Pokémon Go's
July 2016 launch, the app has already been
downloaded an estimated 7.5 million times
in the United States alone--and by the time
you're watching this, that number has skyrocketed.
Nintendo's stock soared as the game outperformed
all expectations. People around the world
have gone crazy for the augmented-reality
installment in the long-running series, which
allows users to catch Pokémon, battle at
Gyms, and collect items in the world around
them. But Pokémon Go isn't all fun and games.
Some players have found injuries, criminals,
and even death on their adventures.
Gotta catch 'em all
For Android users, be wary when downloading
Pokémon Go from any source other than the
Google Play store. The Android operating system
allows users, particularly those who have
"rooted" devices, to download program files
from outside of the official app store and
install them on their phones. For Pokémon
fans living in countries that can't download
the app officially yet, these files are the
only way for them to get early access to the
game.
Additionally, some of these files are targeted
at players who want to game the system. These
"cheat" versions of the app supposedly allow
them to spoof their GPS location in order
to visit Gyms and catch Pokémon without leaving
their couches. The bad news? Enterprising
hackers have taken advantage of the demand
for these files, releasing versions of Pokémon
Go packed with viruses that take control of
the user's phone.
Home Invasion
Pokémon Go developers Niantic are also responsible
for another augmented-reality game, Ingress.
In that app, users are encouraged to visit,
claim, and add local points of interest for
their team, like a global game of capture
the flag. These points of interest were re-used
by Niantic when developing the map used by
Pokémon Go. Unfortunately, this has led to
some mishaps and confusion for players trying
to visit certain Gyms and Pokéstops.
In Australia, one local police station took
to social media to ask players to please stop
wandering into their station in search of
Pikachu. Massachusetts resident Boon Sheridan
has it even worse. He bought an old church
in 2015 and converted it into a home. The
church was previously an Ingress portal, and
is now a Gym in Pokémon Go. Sheridan reported
that he's lost count of the number of players
who have shown up to his residence at all
hours in the day and night. Sheridan has made
the best of the situation, venturing outside
to meet some of the visitors.
The United States Holocaust Memorial Museum
in Washington DC has taken a different stance
on dedicated Pokemon hunters. While it probably
should go without saying, the Museum recently
issued a statement after an influx of misguided
visitors, saying:
“We feel playing ‘Pokémon Go’ in a
memorial dedicated to the victims of Nazism
is inappropriate. We encourage visitors to
use their phones to share and engage with
museum content while here. Technology can
be an important learning tool, but this game
falls outside of our educational and memorial
mission. We are looking into how the museum
can be removed from it.”
Don’t Be Tentacruel
Enterprising criminals in O'Fallon, Missouri
have used the allure of Pokémon Go to draw
unsuspecting players into traps. These criminals
placed "lure modules" on Pokéstops in remote
locations and waited for adventurers to come
running. The modules increase the chance of
Pokémon appearing nearby, which in turn attracts
more trainers to the location to catch them.
After an unlucky player showed up, the thieves
relieved them of their belongings at gunpoint.
"You fools! This wouldn't have happened if
you'd handed over your Pokemon nicely, but
now it's too late for that. So I'm going to
take those Pokemon and destroy you!"
There were 11 such incidents in the O'Fallon
and St. Louis area over the span of a few
days. Eventually the criminals were captured
following another stick-up, and they were
charged with first-degree armed robbery and
Grand Theft Squirtle.
That's definitely not a water-type…
In rural Wyoming, 19-year old Pokémon Go
trainer Shayla Wiggins set out to catch some
rare Pokemon near the Big Wind River.
"I woke up this morning, and I wanted to go
get a water Pokemon, so I just got up and
went for my little walk, for a walk to go
catch Pokemon."
When Wiggins realized she was standing just
a few steps away from a corpse, she called
the police. No word on whether or not Wiggins
ever found that water-type Pokémon.
Prepare for trouble
Niantic may have foreseen some of the issues
related to would-be Pokémon trainers with
their faces buried in their phones, especially
after the multiple tragic deaths associated
with Ingress. When you start up the game,
a warning cautions trainers to stay aware
of their surroundings. But there have still
been reports of players who were a just little
too focused on catching that Flareon and ended
up with various injuries to show for it.
Lindsay Plunkett, a 23-year-old waitress in
Asheville, North Carolina, tripped over a
cinderblock while playing the game and earned
a colorful bruise on her right shin. One Reddit
user claimed that their Pokémon Go adventure ended up with a trip to the local emergency room.
"Oh no! Staryu looks like it's in real pain!"
"It doesn't even have a face, how can you
tell?"
And this is just a few days in. How long until
the Poke-death toll spikes?
Blasting off at the speed of light
While we expected people to get fired from
their jobs for playing too much Pokémon Go,
we weren't expecting someone to get fired
for NOT playing it. An Australian expatriate
had recently relocated to Singapore in order
to take a marketing job for 99.co, an online
real estate portal. When he found out that
Pokémon Go wasn’t available to play in
Singapore yet, he took to social media to
vent his frustration publicly.
Naturally, many native Singaporeans took issue
with his language insulting their homeland,
and started arguing with him online. Instead
of apologizing for his outburst, he doubled
down, claiming that he was there for work
because the locals "can't even read" and were
only good at "mouthing off."
"Dah?"
"Oh no!"
It didn't take long for the man's employer
to find out about his offensive online behavior.
99.co apologized, and he found himself fired
from his position the very same day, which
leaves him plenty of time to catch ‘em all.
Job applications, that is.
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the one
you just saw. And leave us a comment to let
us know what crazy stories you’ve heard
about Pokemon Go...